the r-rated Logan rips wrenches and
roars its way through it's 137 minute
runtime yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's
Jan here and thanks to the success of
Ryan Reynolds brilliant r-rated Deadpool
we now have Logan one of the best ever
x-men movies and definitely the very
best Wolverine movie a film that both
the awesome Hugh Jackman and comic-book
fans deserve yes the year in celluloid
superhero started out great with the
fun-loving parody that was the Lego
Batman movie but standing snarling 180
degrees away from that film's tone is
Logan which takes a high bar set by Lego
Batman turns it to shreds and puts
another even higher bar in its place
star Hugh Jackman and director James
Mangold who already greatly improved on
the x-men first solo outing with the
Wolverine promised something different
with this new movie and they weren't
kidding man goals and his co-writers
Michael Green and Scott Frank have
successfully ripped up the comic book
movie playbook and gone for a full fat
dark and moody western that's
ravishingly shot in all it's rusty dusty
glory by gladiator cinematographer John
Matheson and effectively scored by Marco
Beltrami of course director mangles got
form in the western genre having brought
an excellent remake of the classic 3:10
to Yuma to the big screen and while
Logan channels the likes of Clint
Eastwood's oscar-winning Unforgiven
George Miller's Mad Max series as well
as Hollywood's golden age of westerns it
also worth the influence of the man in
black Johnny Cash firmly on its leave
which is hardly surprising given up man
gold was addressed if you gave us the
cash biopic walk the line and Mangold's
Logan movie doesn't waste time when it
comes to getting its adamantium claws
dirty
in fact it dives headfirst straight into
the kind of action you can expect her
out to get quick cutaways this action is
visibly brutal bloody and a hundred
percent full on and certainly earns it
our rating indeed from start to finish
the whole film is filled with WTF
moments props go to Logan stunt team to
numerous incredible fight scenes each
one more flinch inducing and crazy than
the last yet each of which feels so raw
and authentic that they cleverly hide
the hard work that's gone into
choreographing and executing them and
the movie sound department outdone
themselves - especially when it comes to
the action scenes as a sound of
those mutant claws ripping and piercing
through everything in sight is spot-on
and it's just perfectly excruciatingly
plus the some horrifyingly good visual
effect work from the movies VFX team
this Logan is untamed and untrammeled he
may be totally vicious but he's also
scarred and hurting badly we've not seen
him quite like this in the x-men movies
before and Hugh Jackman gives a
pitch-perfect performance really making
you feel just how worn out rundown and
weary this Wolverine really is and
Daphney keen may be a newcomer to the
big screen but as Laura he matches
jackman superlative performance
throughout she really is that good the
way she moves the way she attacks the
way she eats and the way she
communicates only view and absolutely no
doubt just how feral her character is
add to that the fact that Keane is as
good at playing the humor and tender
moments as well as the more physical
scenes and we have a real potential
future star in our midst
actually the quality of her performance
reminds me the first time I saw Hailee
Steinfeld on the big screen in the Coen
brothers True Grit
and also Milly Bobby Brown as 11 in
stranger things as for Patrick Stewart
as a 19 year old Professor X what can I
say except just like Jackman and Keene
he's exceptional at wringing out every
last drop of anguish heart and humor
from the script
speaking of humor Stephen Merchant
brings a nice dose of that to the film
of the mutant tracking Caliban apart he
plays superbly while Boyd Holbrook puts
in an effectively nasty turn as Donald
Pierce who's out to get Laura along with
Richard II grants evil scientist who
unfortunately doesn't get a great deal
to make a particular impression with to
sum up James Mangold's Logan is a bold
and satisfying cinematic cake on the
much-loved x-men character in his final
outing donning those adamantium claws
Hugh Jackman skillfully steps up to the
challenge of creating a character in a
film that will likely be held up as
benchmarks for future comic book to
celluloid adaptations while Patrick
Stewart and Daphne Keene joined Jackman
in giving stand out terms in a film that
never shied away from the nasty
realities of its world
make sure you see Logan on the big
screen as soon as you can as for me I'll
definitely be watching it again now what
are you looking forward to about Logan
or if you've seen it what did you think
of it and what other comic book
characters would you like to see get the
r-rated treatment
let me know in the comments below I've
got more Logan videos on the way
including Easter eggs in the movie so
turn on your notifications for flicks in
the city to make sure you catch all my
latest videos
and if you enjoyed this video do share
it and subscribe for more reviews Easter
eggs and crazy movie and TV facts some
of which you can check out by tapping or
clicking the screen here thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers